each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's my pleasure to introduce li jian
liu from university of illinois
urbana-champaign she is completing her
PhD at UIUC with professor Terry capital
jahir and before moving to UIC she was
at University of Virginia working with
Professor Tareq and Jack stankovich her
research interest is in programming
models and tools for distributed Network
embedded computing such as sensor
networks and we will hear more about her
research from a talk now ok hello
everyone welcome to today's talk today I
am very happy to come to Microsoft and
talk about my research today I'm my talk
will mainly cover a major piece of my
PhD research which is in verse with a
programming framework to reduce the
development costs in wireless sensor
networks before diving into the details
of today's talk let me introduce myself
a little bit my research interests are
focused on wireless sensor networks I
have worked on multiple directions in
Wallsend networks including programming
paradigms middleware services and the
integrated systems today's talk will
mainly cover a high-level programming
paradigm proposed and the couple of the
mineral services are developed and I
will also show you results we collected
from a couple of real the real deployed
systems first what is wireless network a
sensor network is a network of sensing
devices each of such device may have a
microcontroller to do computation and a
radio to allow them to talk with each
other and the each of them may also have
sensors and actuated to allow them to
sense and react to the environment this
protects ratios are a representative of
our sensor node which is developed by UC
Berkeley we caught a mode so certain
networks have actually received lots of
attention in recent years because of
their unique features they are so small
in size that they can be deployed
anywhere they can be seamlessly embedded
into the environment and interact with
the environment and also they can be
carried to anywhere as you want and they
can operate without the attention
of administrators initially a certain I
was are introduced to the military
applications like targeted checking and
the bot border control later on people
are applying centenaire words to a
broader category of applications like
peoples environmental scientists are
using then to monitor the nature and the
creators and also they can help with
agriculture and they can help to protect
important infrastructures like the
Golden Bridge nowadays and in the near
future we will see sending I was being
applied to even a broader category of
applications they like they can be used
the two I respond to disasters like
cucina they can be used to control
inventory in supermarkets like Walmart
and they can also use it to control the
traffic jams in big cities like Seattle
and they can also be used to help the
baby boomer generation live more
independently and they can also make the
payment more interactive like we two did
with their accelerometers and also they
can help to guide visitors to an hour
occupied parking space wherever they go
like the space monitor application
developer here by Microsoft Research so
but a fundamental challenges that
prevents any network technologies to be
a widely adopted is the difficulties in
Scenario application development why
application development is so hard
incense networks ah there are a couple
of reasons first Sentinel applications
have has to be developed in our
advantage away give away rather than a
float away which is more straightforward
because they have to handle the high
bandwidth have high high frequency
interrupt from the i/o devices including
sensors and actuators also our certain
networks the program of science Network
has two are like define the behavior of
each individual notes instead of defined
the overall behavior of the whole system
so that program has to explicitly define
which are what what's in order to do and
how they should interact with each other
and also sensing that was actually are
running on embedded devices which means
they have very little run time
visibility like my cousin modes we are
working with a lot they only have three
lads to printf that means during the
bugging
you only have sleep bit of information
you can get and also are the inputs to
send another was actually a dynamically
changing it's the dynamically changing
environment so would you make this will
actually make the output of system and
predict unpredictable and also make our
troubleshooting really really difficult
therefore as a result most of the
counter sensor network programmers are
actually PhD students with very intimate
knowledge of network tech techniques and
they have very excellent system skills
let me give you an example in our
civilian system I'm involved with it
actually took our 10 PhD students to
work on for almost two years to develop
to develop implement and actually test
the system so that is not good the goal
of my research is try to provide enough
development support so that we can lower
the adoption adoption a barrier of
certain arrow techniques make it
available to a much broader community
then how can we reduce the development
costs in certain networks I think the
first thing we should do is we should
provide as a right right level of
abstraction so that sentimental
applications committee can be are
designed and implemented I by using only
describing the overall behavior of the
system instead of we have instead of
requiring the programmers to describe
what each in order to do and how they
should interact second we also should
provide enough middleware services so
that we can isolate the programmers from
a very slow love details like in
distributed storage or in multi-hop
communication also debugging sentinels
are really hard because sensor network
system may fail because of hundreds of
possibilities like sensors may fail
actuators may fail OS may feel because
of not not enough protection and that
the communication spec might be messed
up we should not not just leave the
programmers like a cry before the
thousands of possibilities we should
give them a hand provide enough
debugging facilities to zoom them into
the buggy buggy places that actually
causes the failures therefore I
developed a programming framework called
invites you to try to reduce device
calls from all the three aspects I
mentioned the contributions of invited
including a high-level program called
environmentally immersive programming
short as the IP to rate the abstract
level from individual nodes to physical
objects second I also identified and
developed a lot of middleware services
that can isolate programmers from a
low-level details in distributed storage
and the amount help communication and
finally I also provide us and debugging
tools to facilitate those are infield t
buggy and troubleshooting all these
services in my suite has been
extensively tested using our deployed
systems like the Jeanette which is a
surveillance system and the environment
which is a monitoring system to record
whether vocalization this is the overall
architecture of invite read a poem test
network operating systems and hardware's
we built our framework it includes
high-level objections as it's your user
interface and also we provide a runtime
support library that's to be able to
support the objections during runtime
then I also developed a couple of min
away services including our storage
service and a transport layer protocol
that can help with the eip objections
then by using our ERP objections
programmers can develop the applications
using our high-level objections then we
provide a preprocessor which will take
the input take the application code as
input and integrate the algorithm from
our around her library and the middle
services set and create run hank hold
that can be directly uploaded a
two-wheel our sensor devices like those
mica mica choose my cuzzies and excess
air modes then this modes will be
deployed into the field during the
infield in field experiments we also
provide a debugging facilities that can
help that can help with infinity parking
and troubleshooting in today's talk I
will first cover their objections and
their support library next I will talk
about the storage system we developed
and also I will talk about our debugging
tools are very briefly today I'm not
going to cover the chance for the layer
service would have developed and also
I'm not going to talk about the
preprocessor
let me start with the objections so
before I go into details of our
high-level objections let me a giver
overview of the existing program
paradigms in the center was initially we
have those node based languages like an
SC which can actually allow programmers
to define the behavior of each node to
define how they interact with each other
later on people are proposed a lot of
high-level objections like the event
based models actually a lot of
programmers who divine events and define
how the system respond to those events
then the group based models models and
narrow as sensor groups and allow
programmers to operate at the group
level then the query based models
actually models as narrow as databases
and the virtual machines actually allow
users to freely upload and execute the
new code to the sensor network however
one important opposition is that the
unique feature of wireless sensor
networks which is its distributed an
interaction with the physical
environment is not not real capture in
all the existing our paradise so but why
should we capture this interaction with
the physical environment let's take a
retraction of the objections into in
traditional distributed systems taking
this distributed file system as as an
example in distributed file systems
instead of give the program at the view
of interconnected servers they actually
directly present the view of directories
and files that are more interested to
their users of the file systems so
similarly instance networks we should
not provide other programmers a view of
like natural worker of distributed notes
or a view of another clusters instead we
should the directory presented a
physical world to the programmers
because that that is what they are most
interested in we should provide a
logical view of the physical physical
world directly to the programmers that's
the main idea of our environmental
immersive programming basically we try
to revolve our objection directory upon
the physical world so this is
environmental immersive programming we
proposed short
eip yah he basically try to map the
physical entities in the field into
logical objects in in the logical world
basically they allow programmers to
operate on a virtual world of logical
objects instead of the physical world of
physical entities so each of such large
objects will have optical main object
ids and they the objects will only be
instantiated when the corresponding
physical entities are detected in the
field and as the physical entity is
moving around in the field our objects
will follow them migrating from one set
of nodes to another set of nodes and
also programmers can encapsulate the
aggregated state of the physical entity
into the object then they can also
freely define tasks for the object so
that as those tasks will be always be
executed in the vicinity of the physical
entity then are to be able to accomplish
more complex ghosts we also allow users
we also allow objects to talk with each
other by using a remote task invocation
let me give you an example like here
assume programmers have defined like
three type of objects like base station
person and the vehicle they basically
need to define the sensitive sensory
signature of each of such object and
also define the aggregated state and
also tasks this space station don't have
any sensory signatures because it's
static then you're insisting
initialization a base station object
will be instantiated during seasonal
utilization then later on when a vehicle
enters the field I to what we get it
detected and we will automatically
associate a vehicle object to the to the
physical entity and this of pico object
can actually use remote task invocation
to report its current an aggregated
state which is the estimated position of
the vehicle back to the base station
object using this remote tasking
invocation no matter this opportunity
moves in the physical world our logical
option will follow it and the continuous
reporting their reporting is kind of
location to the base station and when
another type of physical entity enters
the field which is the person we will
also automatically instantiate a
personal object to be associated with
the with
actual person so how such object based
objections can be supported at runtime
next I will talk about our runtime
support library to actually implement
these objections in our around town
library we actually provide a different
kind of optical management algorithms
for different type of physical entities
like for those entities that are small
influence of sensory signature and that
are moving really fast we provide a
checking objects examples including like
moving vehicles are moving persons in
the field and then for those physical
entities with large sensory signature
and are not moving so frequently and we
provide the regional objects so
basically this is always a huge are
sensory signature and they are not
moving so frequently then for those are
physical entities that are willing to
our presenters and selves to the system
we provide we provide a self-identified
objects examples of those are
self-identified objects including our
like owner of a smart home who's willing
to tell the sensor networks isn't that
he's actually the owner of the system
he's Mike are so was for that kind of
physical entities we provide
self-identified objects today's talk I
will focus on this are checking objects
because they're the most challenging
ones because of first they are a mobile
and also they are not collaborative we
are facing actually a lot of challenges
when we trying to when we try to support
this checking objects including are like
contacts the maintenance which means
like how to instantiate dynamically
intentional object and how to manage the
aggregated stage for the objects and
also including interrupted communication
which is how to allow up dynamic objects
to talk with dynamic objects today I
will mainly focus on this a unique
object representation problem which is
the problem of how to create only one
object for each physical entity and how
we can migrate object as the physical
entity moves in the field let me r tell
you the details of the algorithm using
example when the target enters the field
to be detected by a group of notes they
will actually fall group and the leader
will be elected among them this leader
will actually instantiate this object
and assign a name to this object and it
will also send out heartbeats are to the
neighboring nodes which are the green
green ones to tell them the context of
the object then when object moved to
another location it will be always be
detected by the followers who already
know about the object context so instead
of instantiate a new object they will
just join the kind of object in this way
we can actually maintain our one object
for each entity and then this new set of
nodes would attack the object the road
country we will join the current object
and the old leader has to retire cause
it's no longer sends to target then a
new leader will be liked it and it will
recruit more followers and but the old
followers will eventually forget about
the object after they time out and they
will erase the context of the object to
ensure enough time granularity then as
we can see here this target is always
wrapped by a set of follower notes so
that we're never to move it always get
attracted by the followers so that we
will not create these objects we will
just join the counter object however
this algorithm is not perfect there are
certain conditions it has two met to
ensure unique representation for example
this target should not be sensed by a
node outside the awareness horizon I
mean the follower set in this case this
target is detected by a non follower
node which doesn't know about the object
in that in this case a spurious object
will be created so based on that
condition we can actually derive the
Philip probabilities of of this case are
here there's a there's important metric
which is maximum back of time T this is
used in lead hand off basically our lead
end of algorithm work like this the old
leader will send out to retire messages
then the secondo member is when they
receive the message they will set a
timer which is randomly chosen between 0
to T and the one who
time I expire the first will actually
become the new leader so based on this
our parameters we derive the failure
probabilities as below without going to
the details of the equations the
intuitive is that when the velocity is
really high we are experienced more
failures this is actually proved by our
simulation results this is simulation
results i got from tossing simulator
basically we deployed 40 notes in a 4 10
x 4 grid then there's one target goes
through the field straightaway along the
longer line ideally we should only see
one object because there's only one
target in the field this figure shows
four different target of velocities on
the x-axis the number of objects created
on the y-axis four different percentage
of message lights we can see that
actually our algorithm can tolerate up
to fifty percent message loss when
target of Rosalie is less than four
Queen per second if we assume this unit
grid lens is ten feet then that for
Crede second can be mapped through 89 89
miles power which is already very good
however we do see some spurious objects
created when the velocity is really high
because because of the failure
conditions i've described in the
previous slide there are also are other
cases that are air with the mehfil this
is another case basically if we are not
having enough notes so that there will
be no desert in the field a no data
means of an area that contains 0 node so
if the note that is so large that it's
bigger than the follower then the lead
heartbeat range which is bigger than the
follower set that means we can never
recruit this null and in to follow a set
in this case when there are targeted
travel out of the desert do will be
detected by a non follower and the
superest object will be created another
case for non densities if the pilot is
moving so slow that when the move is out
of the field the followers already
forget about the object in that case a
spurious object will also be created
this two conditions can be mapped to
these two equations which
this size of desert has cannot be too
big so that we will actually miss the
miss the target based on that we can
drive the failure probabilities here we
made this assumption that the nodes are
uniformly distributed in the field so
the number of nodes within a certain
area can be modeled by a binomial
distribution and when the total number
of a total number of nodes are really
huge on this binomial distribution can
actually are be approximated by a
Poisson distribution both based on those
are assumptions we can derive the video
Philip properties as below this equation
actually tells us when the notre density
is high here this R pi r s squared D
means the number of nodes within the
sensing range if the number of nodes
within a century and is bigger than 4.6
this failure property is always less
than 1% that's that can be ignored
however when the no density is not so
high actually the velocity of targeted
really affect our algorithm it shows us
if the velocity is really low we will
experience a higher failure property
when the note density is not so high so
this is the simply she answers video I
assume I assume our nodes are randomly
distributed in the field and so the
number of nodes within an area can be
modeled as a binomial distribution and
then this binomial distribution when the
total number of nodes usual is really
high can be approximated by a Poisson
distribution so based on Poisson
distribution we can say that the
probability that contains zero note in
your area is actually a lambda so this
lambda is that known actually is a known
density
so this is the simulation results we got
notice that this is a different graph
from the from the previous one are here
we are comparing different a number of
Notre failures we're more note we're
more notes felt actually we are seen
less lower note density so for this
simulation we see that when the velocity
is really low actually we cannot
tolerate really high note know the dance
know the failures because when the note
density is is low actually we cannot
check target with very low speed because
the followers had to already forget
about the target then we can actually
tolerate up to fifty percent no failures
when the velocity is between one and
four for both when the velocity is
really low of velocities really high we
do serious objects which is consistent
with the equations we derived now let's
move on to our real test bed here I will
show some experiment results we
collected from a test bed of my Cosimo
my car to mow back are two modes and we
used for t-mike remotes deployed in ER
10 x 4 grid and we use both nest sea and
the inverse route to develop a checking
system actually these two versions are
are different this message for this net
CD version it is actually a node based
language I surprised programmer to
define the behavior of each individual
node in this nasty version each node
will only report their locations to the
base station when you to detect the
target however in the environment
version this this app this estimate the
position of the target is actually main
tended by our command algorithm the
distribution is automatically done in
the field and only the final results is
reported to the base station as we can
see that in terms of the modules are
nasty version used 12 modules but our
inverse with already requires three
modules there in terms of code lens this
nasty version actually requires three
thousand and six hundred lines of code
but our emergency version only need two
hundred lines of code this tells us
actually inverse with the catalog
programmers to write simple code for the
applications
so you have this preprocessor which
converts that into the year I knew as
lines of code have you come that lines
of code versus the native implementation
you see whether they are the same water
magnitude alina ah actually the compiler
version of in my suit is a bit o is
actually larger than the 3600 because we
have those are intelligent a local
operation going on I think it will be a
thousand or two thousand bigger that's
how too much to see yes because these
are actually there's a preprocessor will
only select the required algorithms and
integrates of them not the whole library
let's see the native version you don't
do any aggregation the network each node
sense yes response yes never the
detector noche yes so to try to make
this programming simple we just did a
the simplest scenario which is every
knowledge us report their location back
to base station then the base station
will do some offline analysis to tie
together the country location just for
the goal of the door yes just for the
code on the note
yes including like a routing and
detection algorithms are now I will show
the performance of this two algorithms
to implementation versions the top graph
shows their trajectories of trajectories
we got at the base station we can see
that the children are actually similar
then the bottom graph shows the number
of packets sent at each node we can see
the nasty version actually send more
packets when it's close to the base
station but the inverse read version
actually has a very balanced number of
messages sent out because it does a
local application to be able to reduce
the number of packets so this this tells
us that imaginative the bottle 1 x and y
is the act just at the access so each of
the bar actually shows a note so we have
40 node in the field this shows for this
note how many messages sent out base
station is actually located in there in
this corner in this corner yes
now let's move to our real systems that
are deployed into the physical world
that's because just the fact that you're
not angry yes yes I'm a pretty good
imitation yes that's that's correct
because even try to try to implement
this simplified version of checking we
already used like almost four thousand
lines of a coat if we try to like add
localization into the into the outer if
it will make the lens of there with an
even lot longer and even more
error-prone now let's move to the our
real experiments so this IP runtime
support is actually integrated to to a
real surveillance system called a
virtual net we do not see is a
surveillance system that is used to
detect classify and check different
targets in the field it is we can
actually a check for different type of
socket like a person or person with the
metal objects in his hand or a small
vehicle or a big shock so Regina that is
actually one of the largest effort in
the center community to try to build a
real services systems this results i
will present is actually collected are
using two hundred access and modes show
on the figure and the the readouts
ashrae are collected by a third party
okay so forty thousand lines of code
that's the one about the libraries also
the including the middleware service on
the routing and yes yes putting the
layers that you feel yes and the
protocol see you talk about is the
networking protocol it's about a
daughter of protocols like power
management time simulation and
everything I will show you on the next
slide of the system catcher so basically
this is build upon visualize the build
upon x sm two modes and we developed
like a communication layer and it says
in layer above that we have a lot of
middleware service developer to then
about middle reserves we have this
application layer which actually get the
current location of the target and the
current of velocity of a target then
report to a remote command and control
center which is are far away from the
real deployment and this
remote control center will actuate 10 or
more sophisticated sensors to do a
further classification of the target or
turn turn a camera to take a picture of
the target so this three modules
including checking data equation group
management actually adapted from the VIP
runtime support so this vision at is
actually a collaborative project I'm
responsible for about one fourth of the
code the X scale and I'm on is this the
PXA based model incident small motor
tell us scale model this has a much much
larger process is it are it has a larger
form factor because it actually
integrate post the censor board and the
program the cpu border together into one
board and it has better security that is
pretty similar with my cars emotes but
it has like a PR sensors which is
infrared sensor to detect emotion so you
mean operating system the processor is
it oh yes thing as my cuzzy yes this is
my yes yeah this is run town yours but
we have different drivers because the
hard way is different so you're really
on top of timeliness yes I deny us
drivers oh yeah actually bypass that
the hardware drivers actually is
developed by Ohio State together with
the with the hardware and we saw those
those are most important sensor drivers
and and the read video drivers are are
either provided by Oh a co-op right
bye-bye Buckley then we are building
above that we will build the
communication layer including robust
robust division cheese and a symmetric
detection evidence this is the imaginary
scenario we did with the 200 x sm modes
basically we deployed our 200 excessive
modes on the t intersection of the road
then are the result of the field will be
reported to a remote control and command
center operated by a special operation
command actually we never entered the
conjure and command center they are
collecting results in the command and
control center then our this mode field
actually we also this commanding your
center will actually turn on more
sophisticated fences addictive developed
a far away from the mode Fieldman it's
like here to tell on those most of it
against sophisticated fences to do
further classification and or take
pictures actually we do not have access
to those sensors so we don't know what
what are those sensors this is the
actual deployment we'd applied our 200
accel x sm 2 modes on the side of the
road then this is a result collected by
a social special operation command are
this results actually tell us the
average checking era is about 6 meters
then the ferocity calculation error is
about six percent which is very accurate
this results also tells us that
indirectly it shows us that our VIP
runtimes runtime support can actually
check very fast moving targets in the
real deployment so basically in this
part I have covered okay so for this
deployment what
okay chip shoulda actually Department on
the road yes here what's the actual
geometry in other words what's the
average internal distance oh it's 300
meters by 200 meters basically the node
are about five meters apart yes this is
a 200-meter bite of 300 meter by 20
metre field here yes because this exit
sxs em two modes actually has better
performance in terms of communication
range compared with mike aziz so that
allows us to deploy them further
actually in the previous experiments we
did with Mike Hussey's no it's micah
choose we can only deprive the most
about three feet as a part because they
are they have really bad communication
range when they are deployed in on the
grassy ground yeah same thing we use
three type of fences PR acoustic and the
Magnetic to be able to like classify
different targets ok so for person
detection we use the plow yes and what's
the range the PR actually it's range is
really good it can go about her between
five to ten meters it's better than the
magnetic sensors so we actually we had a
very difficult time with a person with
metal metal objects for some sauce Metro
are not huge and they have to work close
to the most to to be able to be picked
up by the magnetic sensors are you can
help present of you yes we can also tell
person from from soldier like with
weapons
so in the first part i covered the high
level program product i proposed and
also showed its promise in a real
deployed system next i will talk about a
storage service we developed at UIUC so
why we need a storage service this is to
allow the objects to deposit their their
states in the network so why we need
that are so far we have assumed a
connected operation model basically all
objects they can actually talk to a base
station the host in the network is
connected with the base station so that
the the run the real time state of the
object can be reported back to the base
station in real time this gives us
benefit of real-time information access
this benefit that actually is very
critical in military type of
applications that like those surveys
surveillance systems but do we really
need a real-time information excess in
all the applications let me give you an
example I recently met an ecologist from
national resources and environmental
science department his name is Michael
Michael is actually studying birds he's
really interested in explain to unknown
phenomenon of about a bird-like one is
those birds that are mostly active at
the daytime they like to see actually at
night and also those words they'd like
to sing at their loudest sound and and
in the highest frequency during the
first light of a day so what hip andrew
is he want to record as a vocalization
of the birds and try to deploy a system
for long term so that he can he and find
out whether this is associated with like
a mating behaviour or something else so
after he heard about our session arrows
he's really interested in using sense
networks through collectible
vocalizations are what he planned to do
is just like to deploy CS narrow into
the field then let them stay there and
collect data for several days of several
months then up to the whole experiment
is done he can get this get to the
sensor back and also the data back well
he and do offline analysis to find out
what's the reasons for those two
phenomenons in such kind of application
scenario actually we do not need a
real-time information access
actually a lot of other applications
fall into the same category at this
application like the great duck island
application and also those we're both in
other words that try to check the
activity of a person so ah we think we
no longer needed the real-time
information access benefit of in such
kind of applications what we should do
is we should just go to disconnected
without a discretion to the base station
this actually even give us more benefits
like we now don't need to worry about
base stations don't need to worry about
how we can pull up the base stations in
the wild earnest and how to protect them
from animals and severe weather like
like the rain in at Redmond and the the
winters snow in our champagne also we
don't even worry about maintaining a
hundred percent connectivity this is
actually really hard when there are a
lot of mobilities in the network in
network so but what we need is a storage
system that can actually use the in
animal storage you can maximize the
integral story to reduce data loss
that's why I develop a storage system
called envira store this in verse
structure can allows those objects to
deposit their observations of the
physical entities in the network and it
will it can actually isolate the
concerns in digital storage management
when the network is actually operating
disconnected Lee it mainly uses two
mechanisms to maximize in a no storage
one is using a dated redistribution
between the individual nodes the other
is try to always take best advantage of
uploading opportunities like the
operators may visit as a fielder as per
ethically bring them we are taking
taking wisdom a PDS then our strategy
actually automatically detect the date
meals and try to upload data as soon as
possible to leave the storage load in
the network using this start sister
actually we are able to develop Cuzco
monitoring a patient called environment
environment can actually detect and
record interest in something in the
field are when the acoustic events are
detected are we will invoke this group
manual
algorithms which is part of the eip
runtime support to dynamically designate
one node in the vicinity of the target
assigned the task of recording then this
node will tonight's microphone to record
a thunder of the object attached a
timestamp to the recorded data and start
into the local fresh of the note then
the part of how to balance the data
between different nodes and how the data
can be uploaded to a base station at a
later time is automatically handled by
inverse door then this group manual
algorithms actually adapted from the eip
runtime have introduced in the previous
slides so you think that that is only
one since another got elected to record
a deer crest of the wave form yes the
others are suppressed yes but so you
assume that the two birds that actually
are see me but you want to very close by
and you only need one sensors to detect
that ah yes yes basically we just detect
us a detective song then within within
the range of this follower within the
awareness Ranger of the group there will
only be one node elected to recorded
sound because we think winning certain
range 111 we caught more recordings
enough so if we actually the two birds
are far apart but it's still tender I
can hear each other you still actually
want to take
I know if you recall both or you would
actually possibly want to use to it
really depends on the distance of the
bird if the bird a thing is so route
that they are detected biases the thing
group of notes only one wheel will start
is recording task so the main purpose of
using a VIP runtime here is try to
reduce the data redundancy try to only
use one note to record the data so this
is the indoor experiment we did with
environment in this experiment we used
my casa modes in the on the test bed as
you'll see on the on the top figure
basically let's target it will it will
go through the fields jittery and and
read the title of our paper then it
stronger will be picked up by one note
at a time at during run time like this
so the retinol is actually the one
elected to recorded the sound so at one
time only one note is recording the
sound also the top Bruno de actually is
is is used as the base line base way the
user will also hold a note in his hand
this note will continue to record as
record the sound of the target as as the
baseline to compare with as a quando
juice so later on we can collect collect
the data from from the sensor field and
the concatenate ISM then we got the
sound wave of the target as we can see
the two waves are pretty similar next we
move to an outdoor experiment what we
did is we deployed or 36 makati modes in
a forest near UIUC campers that is the
satellite picture we get we put the
location of nodes on the map to show you
clearly how they are deployed in the
forest near road this is a data this is
recorded later for four different time
and that this is recorded data for
different space basically we can see
here we are seeing a lot of recorded on
the left or part of the picker because
this is news road there are a lot of
traffic flowing on
then this part we also see a lot of data
first we are really worried about the
examiner we are thinking might maybe
maybe there's something wrong with the
equipment otherwise how can we pick up
some inside of the force later on we
check with the manager of the forest
with we found out that actually there's
another group of students who is who's
doing experiments in the forest the same
day as we as we did so these are
actually there you can see clearly they
are working chases in the forest which
is picked up by our system so that's
about the study service I developed and
how we apply this structure is to build
a monitoring application to record bird
vocalization however in the figures I
showed we actually didn't record any
bird vocalization data because it was in
the winter and it seems all the birds
are actually still in texas or Florida
and having their winter vacations next I
will talk about our efforts in debugging
facilities so why we need a debugging
facilities to reduce development costs
are we had a lot of hands-on experience
with real systems we found that actually
programming is not the hardest hardest
part of application development
development what are you even more
difficulties debugging because sensing
nerves actually lies in the intersection
of a lot of different systems like they
are they have they are actually a
multi-threaded execution which is much
harder than single thread execution
because we because we have to handle
race condition and synchronizations and
also they are embedded systems which has
very little runtime visibility they like
the most we used only has three lads to
printf imagine that how can we bug such
a system and also they are distributed
systems that means there are a lot of
delays unbundle delays between our
communication and their the node may
fail the remote servers may feel we have
to find out whether it's problem of
Notre failures or whether the problem of
the systems and another another
difficulty comes from their input of sin
tener words the inputs to sentinels are
actually the change dynamically changing
environments they are not repeatable
that means the system's behavior
is unpredictable and it's really hard
for us to troubleshoot in such a system
then we decided to do something in the
debugging part two to two more to reduce
the development costs more what should
we start with we think as a first the
first thing we should do before we can
debug assistant is true to make the bugs
repeat themselves so that's why we
developed a lock service code in bar log
in viral can actually capture and replay
the environmental inputs how can we do
that well opposition we have with our
event juvenile s like 10 us is that the
sensory data actually are transferred
from model for modules to modules are
through the function calls and their
practice so what we can do is we can
just log function calls and their
parameters and their original time
sequences and later on we just replace
them in the original time sequence they
are issued so that as if the
environmental inputs are the same as
before like here we should I show that
lock modules and the tested modules in
this system we want to provide a
repeatable input for the tested modules
our programs can easily insert some
simple annotation to their program then
our preprocessor will automatically
integrate in Verilog into their
application code then do the run during
the record stage the input wheel goes
through the modules to modules until
reached out but at the same time the
output of the lock modules will be
recorded by in bar log into the local
flash then later on our during the
replace stage we can disconnect the
output of lock modules from other
modules so that the input actually will
not affect our system output will not
affect the test modules instead the data
are coming from local local flash by in
Verilog and the fifth get fed into the
test modules so that we can provide
repeatable input for the test modules
how good is in Verilog in terms of
replay accuracy let's look at the
results we get from vision at here
basically we used in VAR log in via net
to recorded the output of the three
sensor drive
equally magnetic sensor could scans and
a PR sensor then we replay replay the
output of sensory drivers to see what's
the final output of the system the left
figure actually shows the trajectory of
a person during recording and the right
figure shows the charity of the person
during replay in this experiment we
deployed a 37 micah's emotes in a
parking lot near UVA campus we draw we
like to the person works through the
parking parking lot we can see that
these two figures are pretty similar
which tells us actually in Verilog can
our replay the environmental inputs
accurately so what did envelope actually
helped Internet first it can help to see
like a our system our internal variable
changed during runtime basically in
Verilog allows you to log the value of
variables into flash and the and the
klaxon later this bottom figure actually
shows the voltage we collected at each
mode before and after the experiment
using invalid and also our environment
can be used to see how a parameter can
actually affect the performance of the
system using our using repeatable input
basically we record the trajectory over
we record not share it we record the
sensory input of our vehicle then we
will play it again but we with another
value for the same parameter the topic
figures actually shows the final system
output when we set a different value for
this parameter and the bottom figure
shows the internal since the metrics
that are how they are changing when we
set different parameter values so this
can actually help us to to an array of
parameters without physically produce
the physical objects like before without
in Verilog we have to maybe drive the
car 100 times to be able to do the
excitement but now we just like drive
the car 10 times recorded the other
sensory input then we will play the
recorded recorded data so that we can
turn a real parameters without
physically generate to the target
also another thing in verilog helped
wisp internet is actually it can it can
it can simulate the target so that as if
the target is running faster than before
so we can actually play the recorded
data enough you know faster velocity so
that as if the target is running much
faster than before in this experiment we
did because we are doing it in a parking
lot this vehicle can only drive at maybe
maybe five or ten miles per hour however
with the help of Ambala we can actually
accelerate the vehicle to make it run at
six times of its original speed our
original is five miles now we can
simulate 80 miles power to see how the
system performs for targets that are
moving really fast actually the achieved
a repeatability of environmental inputs
are provided by enviro can allow us to
do more things like we can try to debug
a system you usually when we debug video
net if we drive a car through the field
if the system doesn't work we will say
just like a let's drive the car again
but actually this this time when car
drives through the field again it's the
different sensory signature we may not
see the bug again however with the help
of enviro we can replace the exact
sensory signature of the car and the to
see whether system whether we can change
the code of system to make a system work
in in the second time also it can be
used to compare different
implementations of the same of the of
the same algorithm also we can use it to
ur to statistically evaluate the
performance or assistant without
physically generating the target and
also this recorded data can be fed into
simulators to make simulators more
realistic what's your question is
intimidation a part of environment or is
that normally present are yes we
actually used as a tiny civilization
from Vanderbilt what we did is we first
synchronize the whole system before when
we send out as a recording command then
build in runtime the set times
evaluation algorithm will be stopped
they know long
try to signal the system because we
doesn't want to interfere with the real
application also during group before we
play we will synchronize assistant again
then make sure they can replay the
replay the recorded data simultaneously
another another tool we developed in
terms of debugging is called a sensor
network troubleshooting suite in this
Center troubleshooting switch we try to
apply machine learning techniques to
automate failure diagnosis what we did
is we first collect a lot of data a lot
of different system metrics including
like a pet packet of chases a data can
be collected by lunch intrusive e9
intrusive eavesdropping and also we can
collect the execution chases using in
Verilog and also we we can collect some
environmental measurements use use
additional sensors then in the back end
we will get all the collected data run
machine learning algorithm to find out
what are the subset of the metrics that
are highly correlated with the system
failures so I will give you a simple
case study on the IP runtime basically
what we did is we are collected Padma
traces using overhearing by deploying
extra debugging mode in the field then
we we get all the package traces back
and we are derived a lot of system
metrics like the count of different type
of messages and another time difference
between different messages and then we
mark altmetrics as good as as good
during good period ordering back that
appears that means the period that we
failed in maintaining this unique
representation then using this a matrix
and also the marks are weak actually I
use machine learning techniques
Allison's are two generated rules for
failure cases than 44 successful faces
here we use the machine machine are
learning algorithm called part which
basically generate rules incremental e
for certain case here are the rules
generated by part this m to m to l
actually means the number of messages
sent from members
leaders and the time difference actually
means the time difference between older
a heartbeat from from the country day
and a heartbeat from the previous leader
and this distance actually means the
geometric distance between last leader
and the current leaders these metrics
are actually only a subset of all the
matrix we collected however this elbows
actually tells us that when if the group
only contained 11 leader and no members
artists and will fail that means this
group is only a singleton group we don't
have anybody else to hand off the
leadership and also it shows us if
there's not enough sensory sensory
coverage then our system will fail based
on this are rules derived derived by
this part out with allison we are
actually we can actually understand that
our ways and failed because of not
enough sensory signature then how to how
to improve the algorithm are basically
the developer can go back and think
about it and we found that less a
hundred percent sensory sakura tree
means a lot of no desert one way to
better overcome the desert is to
increase the timeout of followers so
that they will not forget about the
object before the taiga to move out of
the desert so what we did is we just try
to use the larger follow a timeout by
tuning this parameter we actually
eliminated a 47 of forty-seven percent
of the failures so those are my initial
effort on debugging tools basically I
think we are just add to the study
starting point there's still a long way
to go to completely solve the province
in debugging support in conclusion I
give up develop the programming
framework for certain areas called
emerge sweet it support try to reduce
setting up to happen overhead for
multiple aspects including we have a
high level programming objection to hide
tedious details and we have a lot of
middleware services to isolate
programmers from those low level details
in distributed storage and multihop
communication and we also have debugging
tools that can help to reduce infield
backe and troubleshooting cost the whole
framework is actually extensively tested
using real hardware and real deployment
then what's next moyes law tells us we
will assume see the proliferation of
myriads of low cost and minimize devices
being deployed everywhere throughout the
world and they can be globally connected
actually such globally connected sense
networks gives us more challenges from
the aspect of programming we have to
operate on more heterogeneous hardware
and software we have to operate on those
tummy sensor nodes like I've IDs we also
have to work on those very smart or
devices like smartphones or PDAs and
also it has to operate on a
heterogeneous softwares it's made run at
the device may run tiny OS or palm OS or
Windows EE so how can we program across
a heterogeneous hardware and software
that's a big challenge and also we have
to program across different autonomous
domains across the world and this our
programming a tree is operating on
extreme scale because currently
according to statistics we already have
our 1 billion Internet users in the
world we can we will expect that each of
such Internet user may have ten or
hundred embedded devices with them in
the future then that means we actually
operate at an scale of 10 billion or
hundred billions of our users how to
program at such an extreme scale that's
really a big challenge and also we have
to export very diverse application
domains including those healthcare
applications in smart homes or those
inventory management in supermarkets or
those traffic control applications on
the street how to be able to support the
programming of such diverse applications
yet that's also a big challenge another
major challenge comes from the man
maintenance side because now we may have
like 10 billions or hundred billions of
devices then how can we make sure every
one of them are still working and how
can we self calibrate them so that they
can work in any kind of data environment
they are deployed into and also like
when there's various observable in
system how can we find a
the subset of the notes that are
responsible for the failures so we
really need to provide some self
collaboration tools to dynamically adapt
the sensors to they are deployed
environment and we need to provide
online validation tools to make sure
that the sensors are still working after
several months is on several years and
also we need to automate the process of
failure diagnosis so that the failure
point can be automatically find instead
of we send send out like 10 billion
administrators to manage all the sense
all the sensor devices that are deployed
throughout throughout so this talk is
about some collaborative work with my
professor tag a brassiere and professor
John stankovic from University of
Virginia actually we are having a lot of
fun with those modes and the third still
laptops powered by two batteries and I
also want to thank for my colleagues for
their contributions to different
projects this video net is a
collaborative project with a lot of
people I only listened to some of them
and also I want to send my special
thanks to my athani providers including
IOC UVA and as of DARPA and here
microsoft research finally I want to
share some behind-the-scenes stories
with you happened during our deployment
of vision net and Eve are Mike in a
California Florida and and the Berkeley
and the Baltimore and Illinois
usually are we do stay in hotel rooms
but we usually do not sleep there
instead we prefer to sleep in the field
to enjoy the open air and the wind
unfortunately a lot of actors I mean the
most died because of car accidents and
severe winter weather in our filled
at UIUC however finally most of them
survived and we are able to collect like
200 of them on the table as shown here
and we are really happy with that that
ends my talk so please check out the
riddle papers if you are interested
thank you have some time for more
questions
represent
so we only covered a subset of the work
you did on that slightly have the
programming abstractions the storage he
said he also had to work on the amount I
half and other services that needed to
support is and also the debugging you
mentioned so among those your
experiences of these which you find is
actually the hardest apart and if you
actually were to start from scratch
again se the beginning of a graduate
school which we would focus on it'll
begin after you have gone through this
and you find set our I feel the most
needy the tools for ten hours is
actually debugging support because for
in terms of programming we do have a lot
of a lot of languages and different
paradigms to programs and I was however
in terms of debugging we really don't
have enough support debugging is
actually really really hard we actually
like spend about two thirds of our time
in debugging system resident design and
the implementing system because
debugging made the the system may fail
because of a lot of reasons first like
you may have a bug in your code or you
may have bugs in your algorithms or you
may have wrong assumptions about the
environment that's like original you
assume the environment is as a parking
lot but actually when you go to the
physically run you find the environment
changes actually will affect the
performance of system a lot like from my
experience like a we we usually get our
experiments in in parking lot at UVA
then we out when we actually go out to
the field to the prices and we now found
that the system will work in the real
field we have to do a lot of things to
debug the system because the environment
changes a lot like when you deploy on a
grass grunt the communication range will
actually reduce a lot and also the
sensors may not work as expected like
some of our magnetic sensors actually
will actually affect by the wind if
they're strong wind we were actually we
were actually a sense magnetic sense mag
mag metal objects because the window
will blow the antennas those antennas
act
metals and also a strange thing is that
like those magnetic sensors I can
actually be affected by the weather like
whenever we see a sunny day with Wiz
cloud if the cloud happens to cover the
cover this toggle top of the sensor then
the sensor will also see magnetic
readings so for those kind of unexpected
environmental effects you cannot like
Express and when you're designing system
important system you can only find it
when you actually deploy system so
during system deployment since we have
so little or runtime visibility we
really need a lot of debugging tools or
failure diagnosis Torrealba us to zoom
into the exact box that causes the
problem is following this question since
you have encountered so many different
in harmony with the following system you
said if I may debugging the major issue
and so how does this have those are real
real war experience actually
contributing to you to never use this
bit more experience to come back to
modify for example your upper level
abstraction or no properties on I think
if you have a list he'll use this
real-time experience the real works
piercing my next time you might be say
you're watching you buddy ah yes so
basically what i found is that those
experiments actually always give me more
ideas about what direction I should go
like Avenged initially I was just
assigned to this a surveillance system
project so we work a lot with that's
when instances but later on we found
that in other applications x-ray shows
are disconnected they are operated is
connected Lee so there's a need for
storage system and also later on when I
has have more experiences with those are
real deployments we found that debugging
is really hard and also those are to
evaluate system is really hard because
we need to physically generate the
targets that
that that that is a motivation of my
later work so basically every time I go
to the field and have some new findings
actually it motivates my new research in
the next step
any other person
okay thank you thank you